hey babe good news I just like to stop
for a new retirement plan oh it's a
lottery ticket I know it's only like a
one in a million chance but I've got a
good feeling about this one try one in
292 million
when probabilities get that small our
brains have trouble processing them but
for reference you're more likely to
become an astronaut or be killed in a
vending machine accident and according
to some people even if you win you might
end up wishing a vending machine had
taken you out instead let's start with
the basics what is the lottery
essentially it's government-run gambling
Kings emperors and presidents alike
realize that people hate taxes but love
to gamble so lotteries were implemented
to keep revenue flowing in without
causing the peasants to revolt for more
ancient lottery history let's check in
with Danielle from origin of everything
the earliest known evidence of lottery
style gambling dates back to between 205
and 187 BCE during the Han Dynasty in
China it was actually in the form of a
game now called keno that still played
in some casinos today and similar to
modern times most of the revenue went
into funding government projects because
the money for expanding and maintaining
that big old wall needed to come from
somewhere lottery tickets first showed
up in the Roman Empire under Julius
Caesar successor Augustus p2 needed a
little extra cash to fix up some
infrastructure but the prizes didn't
come in the form of money instead
winners got materials like household
items and buku payout similar to what we
have today didn't arrive until the 15th
century in the Low Countries today we
know that region as the Netherlands
which makes sense since the word lottery
actually comes from the Dutch word
Lottery the word lot actually means fate
believe it or not lotteries played a
significant role in the establishment of
America the proceeds from a lottery in
1612 are essential in funding the
establishment of Jamestown by the
Virginia Company and these days almost
every state in the u.s. runs a lottery
and hundreds of other countries continue
to practice so what's the harm
sure
something that's so widespread can't be
that bad right let's start with the
obvious for 99.999999% of people who
play the lottery is a waste of money and
even though most people know that the
statistical odds of winning are
horrendous
people continue to play in droves in
fact 60% of adults report playing at
least once a year but unfortunately the
most dedicated players tend to be poor
households with incomes of less than
twelve thousand four hundred dollars on
average spend a five percent of their
income on lottery tickets and this is no
accident
studies show that lottery ads are
specifically targeted to low-income
groups which is kind of perverse when
you consider that the lottery is
essentially a voluntary tax which is
falling most heavily on the shoulders of
the people who can least afford it and
there are ways that the government could
regulate the industry to keep it from
being such a raw deal in Ireland they
have something called a prize bond which
essentially means players can be entered
into a drawing simply by loaning the
government a couple bucks which can be
refunded on demand and where is all the
revenue from the lottery going anyway
it's kind of hard to say because even
though it's essentially a tax the
revenue is not subject to the kind of
scrutiny that real taxes mark most
states have an earmark for purposes
meant to benefit the public goods like
education or parkland restoration but
there is evidence that suggests the
increased revenue just ends up being a
shell game it's not uncommon for state
legislators to cut back funding to the
exact programs the lottery was designed
to help most notably education and just
increasing budgets elsewhere
finally let's address the core issue
people aren't playing the lottery
because they think they're helping their
fellow man but because they believe the
payout will make their lives better so
does it there have been lots of studies
done on lottery winners over the last
few decades and sometimes their
conclusions conflict no not everyone
ends up miserable or buried under cement
somewhere
large unearned flushes of cash also
known as sudden income shock can have
significantly detrimental effects on
physical and mental health one study
showed that although winners life
satisfaction improved their overall
happiness did not in his book money for
nothing
Edward II huge L interviewed thousands
of lottery winners and said you'd be
shocked at how many wish they never want
this is possibly due to something called
the hedonic treadmill theory this is an
all too familiar phenomenon where as a
person makes more money
their expectations and desires rise in
tandem which results in no permanent
gain and happiness so if you are happy
and satisfied in the first place the
lottery won't change that very much and
if you are unhappy before winning a
massive cash increase can exacerbate
your problem so is it bad to play the
lottery
well yeah it's objectively a waste of
money that feeds an exploitative system
which relies on our collective
participation no matter how small but
that doesn't mean that dreaming about
winning is bad as a matter of fact our
lottery fantasies can be really
revealing what's the first thing you
picture when you imagine winning do you
fantasize about quitting that job you
hate donating to a certain charity
starting that artisanal ice cream shop
you've always dreamed of well you don't
need to win the lottery to get started
on those goals so the next time you hear
about the newest acid payout pay
attention to where your mind
most likely those wild and crazy dreams
have something totally achievable at
their core and that's our two cents
special thanks to Danielle Bainbridge
from origin of everything for
contributing to this episode if you want
more intriguing slices of history like
where the minimum wage came from or why
all shopping malls look the same you can
check out origin of everything on
Facebook and YouTube
[Music]